so I had another person ask me dr. Berg
is it okay to consume butter on a
ketogenic diet I don't want to have a
heart attack okay so let's just talk
about this you're not gonna get a heart
attack by consuming butter butter does
not increase LDL okay it doesn't it does
increase HDL the good cholesterol but
even then even if it did increase LDL
it's not going to be a problem
especially if you're not adding
carbohydrates to the butter okay now
there's 400 different types of fatty
acids in butter so it's a very complex
food 25% of its monounsaturated fats 70%
unsaturated two-point-three
polyunsaturated fats as well cholesterol
in their phospholipids that are needed
to build the cell wall and also realize
that your body makes cholesterol it
makes a lot it makes 3,000 milligrams
every single day okay so when you
consume cholesterol your body doesn't
have to make as much one big benefit of
butter and I'm always gonna recommend
grass-fed butter because it has a lot
more nutrition carotenoids which is a
final nutrient into cough rolls which is
a type of vitamin E but one of the big
benefits is Butyrka acid butyric acid is
a potent anti-inflammatory so when you
consume butchart acid you reduce
inflammation in the gut you decrease the
risk of polyps you also improve insulin
resistance so you're actually lessening
chances of getting diabetes
it also has ability to suppress e coli
and Salmonella
it's loaded with vitamin A D E and k2
some people want to know about G what is
key basically G is butter but they take
out the water in the solids so it's pure
butter oil and as additional interesting
benefits to the colon especially if you
have any damage in the gut and it even
lasts longer it lasts six to eight
months so yes you can consume butter
on a ketogenic plan just make sure it's
grass-fed so to prevent me from running
at a Content I have a new survey I want
to find out what you are interested in
so please fill it out the links down
below